bonsoir à toutes et à tous
je suis d'orient dreuil de la fondation
jean jaurès et je suis très heureux
d'être avec vous ce soir pour animer cet
échange et j'en profite pour remercier
le mouvement démocrate et les jeunes
démocrates de cette invitation et pour
remercier nos intervenants donc très
heureux d'être d'être là pour ce temps
de discussion sur la participation
électorale qui conforte un un sentiment
qu'ont acquis et que dans les temps qui
viennent l'enjeu de la démocratie sera
primordiale et donc celui de la
participation
électorale
quand on voit à force de voir les
chiffres de participation s'éroder et
quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui près de 7 6
millions de personnes sont considérées
comme mal inscrits sur liste électorale
et 5 millions non inscrits ce qui est
cumulent un total de 25 % du corps
électoral qui est qui est mal inscrits
ou non inscrits sur les listes
électorales et donc comment comment
est-ce qu'on va comment est-ce qu'on
peut sortir de ce que jean yves dormagen
1 et céline braconnier appelle la
démocratie de l'abstention
on aura des pistes de réflexion ce soir
en croisant les regards grâce à six
parcours si vision six parcours militant
6,6 regard différent donc je vais vous
présenter notre notre table de ce soir
que je remercie d'être d'être là avec
nous donc antonin dacosse qui est
responsable jeunes du mouvement
générations nolwenn henry qui est
conseillère municipale à quimper donc
qui vient en voisine et militante
d'europe écologie les verts ambroise
méjean président des jeunes avec macron
alexandre abonnés qui est délégué
national des jeunes républicains en
charge des jeunes pros aux plus hautes
qui est président des jeunes démocrates
et arnaud platel qui est conseiller
municipal dans le finistère qui
également régional de l'étape et
militants du parti socialiste donc ce
que je vous propose c'est un temps
d'échangé autour de deux horizons le
premier jusqu'en 2022 quel récit quelle
technique est le quelle manière de
quelle manière on fait campagne pour
faire reculer l'abstention d'ici
l'échéance présidentielle et
législatives qui suivront et le deuxième
horizon-là près qu'est ce qui se passe
après après 2022 et arnaud je vous
propose peut-être de de commencer par
vous sur sûr je crois ce que vous
appelez la france qui s'en fou pour
reprendre l'expression de la fondation
jean jaurès et donc comment est ce qu'on
parle pas aux gens qui font déçu au kiné
qui ne votent plus
en enlevant idées
oui c'est bon vous m'entendez avant de
commencer sur cette question là moi
d'abord je voudrais dire une minute pas
plus sûres déjà pour vous remercier pour
l'idée de cet internement notions et
surtout sur le sur le format est pour
vous dire comme je suis ravie
d'intervenir sur un format au delà des
étiquettes politiques et pourquoi ça
concerne le sujet parce que je suis
premier à dire que s'il faut défendre le
clivage gauche droite et moi je crois
encore qu'il existe peut-être que c'est
la différence avec beaucoup d'entre nous
ici du premier aussi à dire que dans les
situations d'urgence et nous en vivons
une
actuellement que ce soit vis-à-vis de la
crise sanitaire et aussi sur ses
conséquences sur la jeunesse des ponts
entre nous doivent être trouvées je vais
faire rapidement de l'histoire
après la guerre il a fallu reconstruire
puis moderniser la france c'est le
moment où les communistes gouverner avec
de gaulle par exemple le plan monnet
cannes et à la modernisation du pays
faisait travailler entre eux sous
l'égide de jean monnet des hauts
fonctionnaires des experts des élus de
tous les bords politiques et je crois
que là-dessus quelque part toutes
proportions gardées un format sur ce
type là sur un sujet comme ça au delà
des étiquettes politiques je trouve que
c'est essentiel donc je voulais vous
remercier là dessus parce que
aujourd'hui on n'est pas prêt guerre
mais il s'agit quand même de
reconstruire la france posco vide enfin
la france est en difficulté avant la
crise sanitaire mais aujourd'hui de
façon plus urgente
aussi bien sur le plan matériel
l'économie que sur le plan moral et
politique
or et c'est là où on en vient aux sujets
sans la jeunesse ne dit parviendront pas
à reconstruire cette france a remué
afghaniser cette france alors posco vite
j'ai pas si on peut dire ça mais en tout
cas c'est la situation actuelle on a
besoin de la jeunesse parce que c'est
très cliché ce que je vais dire mais on
a déjà besoin de leur dynamisme ça on
n'invente rien là dessus ça fait
toujours un peu vieux vieux con de dire
ça mais c'est important de dire que la
jeunesse on a aussi besoin de leur
dynamisme mais aussi sur le fond parce
que là je parle de la forme sur le fond
c'est important de d'écouter les jeunes
dans le discours politique pour pouvoir
s'adapter aux enjeux à venir que ce soit
sur le réchauffement climatique et
nolwenn en parlera notamment sur la
mobilisation des jeunes sur cette
question là que sur les nouvelles
technologies ou que sur les questions de
parité donc on a besoin aussi sur le
fond de la jeunesse et janvier encore
plus ce sujet le problème c'est que la
jeunesse justement elle s'abstient de
plus en plus là dessus et pâques
électoralement mais bon c'est c'est le
sujet je voudrais juste dire que selon
moi la différence sur la nature de
l'abstention et qui est exacerbé chez
les jeunes c'est que jusque récemment
moi je ne pourrais pas le dater mais
l'abstention elle ressemblait plutôt à
une france qui qui en avaient marre des
élus en avaient ras-le-bol le fameux
tous pourris ça sert à rien de
participer aux élections parce que de
toute façon les élus sont guidés par le
grand capital enfin toutes ces questions
là il ya toujours cette opinion la qui
restait quoi qu'on en pense une opinion
politique le ras-le-bol l'abstention qui
s'explique par leur ras-le-bol
aujourd'hui de plus en plus s'agrège à
ce ras-le-bol
dorian le disait une france qui s'en
fout alors c'est vulgaire de dire ça
mais puisque d'orient et là c'est le
titre d'une très bonne note de la
fondation jean jaurès sortie je crois
dans le cadre des élections dont je suis
pas l'auteur mais très bonnes notes très
bonnes notes dans le dans la perspective
des dernières élections de cette france
qui qui en plus de celle qui en a
ras-le-bol finalement
voix
c'est même pas un sujet pour elle
d'aller voter c'est c'est complètement
étranger à eux que d'aller voter et
c'est pour ça que le titre est un peu
vulgaire mais parlant mais parler d'eux
parlant de cette france qui s'en fout
donc je suis persuadé d'abord que si on
veut analyser l'abstention général
exacerbé chez les jeunes faut d'abord la
nommer est de plus en plus il ya une
perte du sens civique chez beaucoup
d'entre nous alors les raisons à ça pour
venir aux propositions ensuite je le
disais la perte générale du sens civique
avec une montée de l'individualisme
exacerbé peut-être chez les jeunes en
gt2 pas le faire je vais peut-être me
faire des ennemis 6 mai on peut pas
juste dire que les gens et les jeunes ne
se rendent pas aux yeux parce que c'est
la faute aux états c'est la faute aux
élus la preuve c'est que les élus
municipaux par exemple qui restait un
peu
protégés de ceux de ce ras-le-bol et 17
abstentions de plus en plus sont élus
avec une part infime du corps électoral
alors que pour le coup c'est très
concret pour les gens mais c'est quand
même la preuve d'une perte du sens
général du sens civique et ensuite je
reviendrai plus lors de la deuxième
question une absence majeure
de différence majeure entre les projets
vont s'agiter je suis peut-être pas
d'accord avec certains d'entre vous mais
pas moi je défends le clivage gauche
droite je le défends parce que pour moi
il existe et parce que pour moi il est
souhaitable parce que si on pense que
tout le monde on est dans le même bateau
etc c'est la même chose forcément ça
crée un effet démobilisateur qui se
vérifie chez les jeunes troisième raison
selon moi c'est que le discours
politique et la vie des partis et là
dessus on est tous concernés ressemble
de plus en plus à une langue étrangère
et un entre soi les gens ont
l'impression que c'est pas pour que
c'est pas leur monde de toute façon et
que ça sert à rien d'aller voter parce
que c'est un comportement qui n'est pas
qui est qui qui leur revient pas et
enfin et je reviendrai là dessus aussi
une rationalisation extrême du politique
une des raisons de l'abstention selon
moi c'est qu'on a une technicisation des
élus c'est à dire que de plus en plus je
suis élu je me mets dedans en fait plus
de technique on gère les affaires
courantes et beaucoup moins de la
politique on ne résout pas la crise dure
est-ce qu'on vit actuellement donc
forcément ça crée un effet
démobilisateur et je termine vraiment
par là parce que je vois que le temps
presse sur les propositions mais je
développerai plus sur la deuxième partie
parce que là la question je crois que
c'était pour 2022
déjà là aussi je vais faire des ennemis
il faut que les jeunes ils aillent voter
point ses tresses et très bas taux de
dire ça mais je disais tout à l'heure il
n'y a pas que des causes externes à
l'abstention il faut que les jeunes on a
besoin d'eux je fais appel à leurs
responsabilités à leur utilité à leur
adaptation aux enjeux à venir il faut
qu'ils aillent voter il faut qu'on
délivre ce message là ensuite il faut
assumer nos clivages je suis de gauche
je suis certainement pas d'accord avec
beaucoup d'entre vous et ça il faut
l'assumer il faut même le chérir parce
que ça crée un effet mobilisateur et
enfin de façon plus matérielles sur les
élections qui arrivent et la tête je
vais faire plus plaisir à certains ces
quais il va falloir très concrètement
investir des jeunes faire confiance à
des jeunes électoralement leur donner
l'investiture pour qu'à un moment on
n'oublie pas que notre démocratie elle
est représentative et que quand tu
donner les chiffres de ce qu'on
considère comme jeune homme jeune c'est
un peu on sait pas trop ce que ça veut
dire parce que selon l'insee ces 15 24
ans mais en même temps on a dit de
macron qu'il était jeune qu'il a été élu
très jeune que c'est très large mais je
crois qu'en tout cas pour être vraiment
donné du lustre à la démocratie
représentative
on n'a pas oublié que cette démocratie
représentative doivent représenter
toutes les couches de la société et
notamment les jeunes donc il faut les
investir pour les prochaines élections
qu'est ce qu'être jeune
qu'est ce que la jeunesse on en a
peut-être plusieurs segments alexandra
toi tu tues tu travaillais plus
particulièrement sur les jeunes pros
comment est-ce que quel est ton regard
toit plat dessus sur sur les jeunes
professionnels
justement c'est marrant parce que en
fait je suis la seule de droite ici
le côté du club on sentait un peu seul
et en fait finalement je mets en
chantrans me rendre compte que je te
rejoins sur tellement de points
heureusement qu'on est là pour débattre
et heureusement qu'on est là pour se
réunir et en même temps sur ce qu'il
peut me surprendre de temps en temps
j'ai peut-être des questions à me poser
un nom parce qu'en fait non j'ai
expliqué pourquoi je suis d'accord avec
toi sur beaucoup de points c'est que en
fait je pense qu'on va tous être
d'accord sur le constat est ce que tu as
fait c'est du constat le constat c'est
les jeunes ne vont plus voter point bas
les jeunes effectivement aujourd'hui ils
ont rien à voilà c'est dit
clairement et là dessus on est tous
d'accord
c'est vrai que moi je travaille plus
particulièrement sur les jeunes
professionnels alors nous chez les
républicains ce qu'on appelle jeunes
c'est les 15-35 donc moi même jusqu'à 35
ans donc est-ce qu'on est encore j'en à
35 ans je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on a décidé de faire et on
travaille je travaille vraiment sur 7
sur cette catégorie très spécial qui est
celle des jeunes pros donc des jeunes
actifs qu'est ce que c'est un jeune
actif c'est quelqu'un donc qui rentre
dans la vie active mais c'est pas
forcément quelqu'un qui a son premier
contrat ça peut être son deuxième son
troisième 100 4e
c'est aussi quelque chose voilà pendant
combien ça qu'on retrouve partout
et en fait le souci qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est que les politiques ne parlent plus
à ces gens là et en fait c'est pour ça
aussi qui ne vont plus voter je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez ça a fait ça a été
très médiatisée il ya un sondage le
monde qui était sorti au mois d'avril de
cette année qui disait que la tranche
des 25 34 donc mais je ne provoque pas
me joindre pro votent majoritairement
rassemblement national ça avait fait un
tollé en disant c'est pas normal
pourquoi est ce que cette catégorie
votre rassemblement moi je vais vous
dire un truc faut aussi que en fait on
arrête d'être choqués par ce genre de ce
genre de titres en tout cas et par ce
genre de sondage tout simplement parce
que cette catégorie là il faut bien
qu'elle vote pour quelqu'un et elle va
voter pour les gens un peu tout cas pour
les politiques qui vont leur parler et
les choses font que deux pieds 2017 qui
a parlé à cette catégorie là c'est
marine le pen c'est marine le pen donc
forcément ils vont voter pour elle ces
gens là pareil dans ce sondage on
apprenait qu'en 2017 29% donc des 25 34
ans a vivoté mâcon aujourd'hui sur le
donc en avril parce que je dis pas
aujourd'hui parce que des choses ont
changé avec l'apparition de zemmour dans
le clivage politique mais en avril 29 %
des 25-34 étaient prêts à voter pour
marine le pen en 2022 et maquereau a
perdu 10 points conquis et passer à 20%
des intentions ne sont pas des
intentions de vote mais pourquoi c'est
enfin la réponse est toute simple c'est
que en 2017 ces jeunes professionnels
chercher quelqu'un qui allait leur part
les mâcon cela dit il arrivait c'était
quelqu'un de dynamique quelqu'un de
jeune va en tout cas ont constaté qu'il
était jeune qu'il était dynamique qu'il
était un peu nouveau entre guillemets
sur sur la scène politique c'était la
start up c'est la soi-disant start up
nation jean chemise blanche n'est ce pas
waze voilà basket et
donc les voilà ces gens là se sont
retrouvés en macro à l'image de macron
haïti ont dit on va voter pour lui c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé derrière alors macron n'a
pas eu de chance malheureusement mais il
a eu pas mal de problèmes là dessus je
le reconnais au moins il avait pas mal
de problèmes pendant son quinquennat
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que en
fait toutes les promesses entre
guillemets de début de mandat ne se sont
pas fait c'est à dire que tous les
discours qui ont été faits ont été
menées sur les étudiants ensuite on a eu
la crise coville qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant la crise que vit dans tout
cas aux premiers confinement les uns
dernière on a dit les étudiants les
pauvres ils sont distants ciel ils ont
plus de rapports sociaux ils ont perdu
leur taf étudiants ce qui fait qu'ils
peuvent plus payer leur loyer ils
peuvent plus vivre entre guillemets leur
vie d'étudiant ok c'est très bien
c'était totalement la réalité
donc ensuite toutes les mesures qui ont
été faites derrière ont été faites pour
les étudiants pour aider les étudiants
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait pour les
jeunes actifs c'est ça la question aussi
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui venait
juste d'être diplômé ou quelqu'un qui a
été diplômé il ya un an ou deux ans
qu'est ce qu'on a fait pour eux ce qu'il
faut pas croire qu'un jeune quand il
sort de quand il vient d'avoir son
diplôme il un cdi tout de suite non un
gène quand il sort d'un diplôme il
enchaîne les cdd la plupart du temps
sauf que quand il ya ulcos vide ils ont
perdu leur cdd et qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pour ces jeunes là on a en fait personne
n'a parlé mais nous aussi un jeu dire la
droite aussi leur a pas parlé ou alors
on n'a pas parlé à ces gens là donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui soit ils ne
votent plus ce qu'on disait soit il vote
extrême parce que marine le pen leur a
parlé alors peut-être qu'à leur a parlé
en leur annonçant monts et merveilles ce
que fédère jean luc mélenchon aussi un
jeu passe vous souvenez aux campagnes
mais 17 quand il disait qu'il fallait
donner 800 euros par mois à tous les
jeunes forcément tous les jeunes ont
voulu voter pour lui mais bon après on
sait très bien que c'est pas réalisable
mais marine le pen leur a parlé donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui ils veulent
voter pour les extrêmes donc je pense
qu'il ya un gros sujet sur vraiment
cette catégorie des jeunes
professionnels il va falloir qu'on
réussisse à leur parler et là je met
tout le monde dans le même dans le même
panier faut qu'on réussisse a alors
parlé et qu'on réussisse à trouver des
ambassades des réponses à leurs
problématiques leurs pratiques qui et
comment trouver un taf tout simplement
comment trouver un logement parce que je
les fais moi même j'ai bon ben j'ai eu
trois appartements comme ça que j'ai dû
me faire passer pour étudiants monti à
me faire passer pour étudiantes parce
que quand on est jeune pro qu'on a un
cdd et en fait on veut pas de nous pour
un appartement parce que en soi disant
on n'est pas solvable donc trouver un
logement tu toi un travail à la hauteur
de ses compétences trouver un logement
et c'est toutes ces réponses et qui sont
pas toutes ces questions qu'ils sont
bêtes qui sont juste ce qu'on a tous
envie d'avoir mais personne ne leur
parle et je pense que c'est un gros
sujet sur l'abstention
nolwenn comment est ce qu'on parle aux
jeunes aujourd'hui et comment est ce que
toi tu leur thürler ça fonctionne
parfait là où je vais mais tp est à la
fois d'accord avec toi
pas d'accord c'est que
beaucoup de gens disent qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes les jeunes s'en foot mais je
pense que cette abstention massive des
jeunes et a contrasté avec
ba tout leur fort engagement sur de
nombreux points on voit avec la marche
pour le climat qui a quand même
rassemblé 350 mille personnes beaucoup
de jeunes sur leur mobilisation sur deux
sur de nombreux thèmes donc une forme et
une forte mobilisation pardon à la fois
étudiante lycéenne mais le premier qui
se posent fait cette jeunesse justement
qui est motivée qui se bat qui se
mobilisent c'est qu'ils ne se sentent
simplement pas écouté et part
représentée par le gouvernement je
prends la question de l'environnement la
safer clichés entre écologie les verts
mais comme ça continue
sur ce cliché là par exemple parce que
sur ce point 9-8 je vais donc
on a lu un rapport du gier qui a bien
montré notre inaction la france a été
justement condamnée plusieurs fois
notamment nous dernier par rapport à son
inaction et alors que les jeunes sont
350 milles présents dans les rues pour
ça notamment donc comment on veut que
les jeunes aillent aux urnes
s'ils ne se sentent pas même entendu et
avoir la belle en ce pays alors que
c'est nous qui vont être impactés
justement par les mesures prises par
l'état donc je pense qu'avant de
réfléchir sur comment inciter tous les
jeunes à voter il faudra savoir pourquoi
ils ne votent pas et comme je dis
beaucoup de jeunes ne se sentent pas
concernés
et là où je vais constrastée contrastée
et plutôt avec toi en disant que
peut-être les étudiants seraient
beaucoup plus privilégiés sur sur
certains thèmes
je suis pas d'accord quand on voit déjà
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macro on se
pose encore plus à des nations on a une
diminution des appels douglas a touché
les jeunes aussi beaucoup les étudiants
la mise en place d'un parcours sud qui a
été catastrophique
une hausse des droits d'inscription à
l'université
c
j'ai vécu il ya besoin donc si si
une une race une hausse du droit
d'inscription de 1,2 pour cent alors que
les jeunes sortent une crise sanitaire
mais aussi une crise économique et
justement quand je parle des étudiants
je suis concerné parce que je les ai
vécus également on pensait qu enfin le
gouvernement allait réagir et qu'on
allait être aidé par rapport à ça alors
qu'on une fois pas du tout et ce fut
même pire par exemple il ya une aide
exceptionnelle normalement attribuées
aux étudiants fin aux jeunes dans
l'ensemble est en fait on s'est rendu
compte que les étudiants n'étaient pas
concernés par cette aide alors que
pourtant c'est ce qui était rattachée
dans les médias voilà encore une fois on
n'est pas considérée et sur le sujet je
vais faire vite mais c'est son pendant
cette crise sanitaire ce sont les
étudiants eux mêmes qui se sont bougés
pour créer des épiceries solidaires
parce qu'il y avait quand même des
jeunes qui ne pouvaient pas se payer un
repas par jour c'est le truc je trouve
ça fou et donc il est sensé que nous
saisissons justement de des questions de
jeunesse et des jeunes aussi pour
construire avec eux c'est important
avait que des propositions
programmatiques pour pour les échéances
à venir donc la question après ça c'est
comment intéresser les jeunes donc on a
vu lors des dernières élections une
abstention massive lors des élections
départementales et régionales qui sont
qui touchaient surtout les jeunes et
qu'une 85 % de taux d'abstention et il
faut vraiment se demander les causes et
quand je parlais avec des gens de ma fac
avec des étudiants des jeunes son avis
professionnel ou pas ce qu'ils m'ont dit
c'est à la fois ils ne se sentaient pas
concernés et ils n'étaient pas informés
et je pense qu'on a beaucoup à jouer sur
les informer informer là dessus
beaucoup de gens ne savaient même pas
qu'ils avaient des actions par exemple
des élections départementales et
régionales en même temps même des gens
qui venaient au bureau de vote ce qui
peut paraître assez fou
et beaucoup de jeunes en fait ne
connaissait pas en fait les compétences
de la région ou du département j'étais
assez précises mais c'est ce que je sais
ce que gervais et ne penser que ça ne
contiennent ni concerné tout simplement
pas alors que si donc c'est un travail
d'information et qui pour moi devrait se
faire en utilisant des nouveaux canaux
d'information comme par exemple les
réseaux sociaux parce que voilà il faut
être faut être réaliste et les
plateformes sur lesquelles les jeunes
sont les plus présents et donc pouvoir
les informer via ses réseaux sociaux
pour moi peuvent être un bon moyen de
les informer et de les inciter à venir
on voit beaucoup de politiques actuelles
qui suis normand notamment les réseaux
sociaux pour pour informer c'est le cas
aussi beaucoup de gens au gouvernement
et le résultat est que beaucoup de
jeunes ont accroché avec ça donc donc
voilà donc je pense que saab est à un
bon moyen d'inciter les jeunes à voter
et un dernier point donc là encore un
peu un poids revu et corrigé les verts
n'est pas et que parce que ça concerne
génération s et d'autres c'est la
primaire écologiste j'ai trouvé que
c'était une très bonne idée parce que
c'est pour une fois une des rares fois
on va pas imposer un candidat que nous
n'avons choisi dans notre parti aux
présidentielles mais ce sont les gens
qui peuvent choisir leur candidat et si
on se concentre un peu plus sur les
jeunes ça a été ouverte dès 16 ans ça
peut paraître anodin mais c'est voilà
encore une façon de pour les jeunes de
s'exprimer
juste une toute petite précision quand
tu disais la baisse d'apple ça
concernera que les étudiants n'ont
malheureusement la réforme des appels ça
aussi concerner les jeunes trop simple
ans dans le calcul parce qu'avant c'est
un calcul sur tes revenus
deux ans avant et en fait non à partir
du coup de l'année dernière c'est un
calcul par trimestre donc du coup tous
les autres hauts et bas ils ont pu eu le
droit aux apl
ambroise peut-être pas sur les apl mais
comment est ce qu'on
construit co construit comment est ce
qu'on fait la politique avec avec les
jeunes comment est ce qu'on les applique
nous avons les embarquent pourtant mes
éléments de langage leur réponse était
prêt bon déjà je voulais je voudrais
commencer par par vous remercier pour
cette invitation et notamment auguste
depuis le temps dans la majorité qu'on
parle de guidel depuis le temps qu'on me
vante cette université d'été je suis
content d'être parmi vous la première
année où il ne pleut pas d'après mes
informations
la journée n'est pas finie mais vous
n'êtes plus réactif quand on critique la
météo en bretagne que quand on critique
l'action du gouvernement ça m'inquiète
un peu un
[Applaudissements]
nom mais plus sérieusement et et mercier
d'organiser ce débat de manière
transparente eason parce que c'est
intéressant on voit que les lignes en
fait ne sont pas forcément des lignes
politiques et pas forcément sur le
clivage pour le coup qui peuvent exister
mais qui sont des lignes des fois
d'analyser et donc je pense que ces
interrelations qu'on puisse confronter
ses points de vue
vous avez fait un constat globalement
que je partage et je vais pas revenir
dessus je vais plutôt essayer de me
tourner vers la question de quelles sont
les modalités d'action qu'on peut
envisager dans les prochains mois et
notamment dans la campagne
présidentielle qui s'ouvre pour inciter
les jeunes à retourner au vote et tout
ça s'appuie évidemment sur les constats
que vous venez de faire que je partage
grandement il ya un premier point qui
reprend un peu ce que vous avez dit sur
la question de l'intérêt du débat public
et comment est ce qu'on est capable de
montrer aux jeunes dans le débat public
que ce qu'on fait ce qu'on me dit en
politique les concernent directement et
surtout que ça les respecte
je voulais commencer par un petit sujet
qui est la question de la qualité du
débat public vous avez sûrement
peut-être vu passer ça fait pas très
jeune pardon de le dire mais un appel
dans le journal la croix je ne fais pas
de jeunes du tout mais mais qui a été
qui a été signé qui a été signé par par
plusieurs je sais pas si les jeunes
lisent l'accord peut-être chez toi
mais
mais mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'il y à cet appel qui était très
intéressant parce que justement il y
avait la nécessité la volonté de mettre
dix règles de bonne conduite dans le
débat public et je pense qu'on pourrait
tous en tant qu organisation de jeunesse
s'engager à essayer de respecter ça et
ce débat est une des premières preuves
de ce qu'on est capable de faire de la
qualité du débat public première chose
sur le fond la façon dont elles sur la
forme par dont la façon aussi de se
passe ensuite la qualité du débat public
et la casse la capacité qu'ont à
s'adresser aux jeunes sur les
thématiques qui les concernent je vais
prendre un contre exemple qui parce
qu'on parle de baisse de participation
mais moi j'ai un contre exemple qui me
plaît beaucoup c'est la question des
européennes les dernières élections
européennes qu'est ce qui s'est passé on
a eu une augmentation de 8 points de la
participation au global est de 14 points
de la participation chez les 18-35 mais
pourquoi parce que il y a eu une
structuration du débat public sur des
thématiques qui concernait les jeunes et
il ya eu une offre politique claire et
là pardon je mets un coin dans la
question du clivage gauche droite mais
c'était pas le clivage gauche droite qui
intéressait les gens dans cette élection
c'était le clivage pro européen ou
contre l'europe et ça parce que des
partis ont assumé des positions claires
europe ecologie les verts a fait un très
bon score parce que justement la
question écologique était lié à la
question européenne et vous l'avez
exprimé dans le débat public et je pense
que ça a eu un impact électoral positif
nous on offrait avec la majorité
présidentielle une offre extrêmement
clair sur ce qu'on voulait pour l'europe
de demain le rassemblement national
aussi malheureusement même si on est en
désaccord il y avait cette affiche
claire et puis des partis qui étaient
pour le coup un peu plus mitigé sur ce
sujet se sont retrouvés en difficulté
parce que les jeunes n'ont enfin les
jeunes et les acteurs de manière
générale n'ont pas lu d'offre politique
claire et donc cette capacité qu'ont à a
parlé à m dans le débat public des
thématiques et un débat clair et des
offres politiques là aussi un impact
puissant sur la capacité qu'on a à faire
voter les jeunes et donc ça ça me permet
d'enchaîner sur les thèmes qu'on doit
mettre dans le débat public
là je suis d'accord avec ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure sur le fait qu'il
faut s'adresser aux différents publics
il ya effectivement deux catégories de
jeunes les étudiants d'un côté et les
jeunes actifs de l'autre et ils n'ont
pas les mêmes attentes pas forcément pas
forcément les mêmes besoins et on a
beaucoup parlé et je suis d'accord aussi
aux étudiants beaucoup moins aux jeunes
actifs et c'est une des responsabilités
du gouvernement je pense dans les mois
qui viennent avant même l'élection
présidentielle ne pouvoir être en
capacité de s'adresser à des gens à qui
on n'a pas donné de réponse pendant une
partie de notre quinquennat et ça je le
dis avec forme d'humilité sur le bilan
du quinquennat et puis une manière
générale il ya des thématiques qui
transperce un peu ces deux catégories
est la thématique de l'écologie
évidemment même si on n'est pas d'accord
sur la qualité du bilan écologique je
rappelle que en cinq ans on a fait plus
que certains lorsqu'ils étaient au
pouvoir pendant deux ans entre 2012 et
2014 on a fermé des centrales à charbon
par exemple ces quatre millions de
voitures qui sont deux émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de voitures économiser
on a un bilan à défendre mais je ne suis
pas sûr effectivement qu'on soit vu chez
les jeunes comme étant suffisamment
ambitieux sur le sujet je veux bien te
le concéder et donc il ya ce thème là le
thème du pouvoir d'achat aussi pour les
jeunes qui est un thème qui est prégnant
crucial sur lequel on doit faire plus
que ce qu'on a déjà fait même si là
aussi je veux quand même défendre le
bilan du gouvernement même si ce n'est
pas l'objet de cette table ronde donc
l'intérêt du débat public par la qualité
du débat et par le fond ensuite quelque
chose que tu abordé juste à l'instant la
question de la communication comment on
s'adresse comment on parle aux jeunes on
a des ministres qui sont
exceptionnellement je ne crois que ça
ait l'air y est parmi nous c'est la
benjamine du gouvernement c'est à
égalité avec habré la table même jour
d'anniversaire ce sont les deux plus
jeunes ministres de la vème république
et donc je peux dire qu'enfin on envie
de dire qu'on a insisté dans ce
gouvernement sur les personnalités mais
il faut aussi qu'on soit capable
d'adapter la communication il faut
arrêter les campagnes gouvernementales
du un sujet sur twitter avec des vieux
clip tout péter qui ne touche pas les
jeunes il ya quand même des choses qu'on
doit pouvoir faire quand vous regardez
qu'on en discute et tout à l'heure et je
veux rendre à apolline la vice
présidente des jeunes démocrates ce qui
était à pauline mais quand on regarde
tout à l'heure quand on en parlait tout
à l'heure quand on regarde la
communication qui est fait pour les
élections il faut qu'on soit capable
d'être d'innover un petit peu quand on
voit que 50 % des jeunes sont sur
instagram les titres 24 ans sur
instagram tous les jours 33% sur tik tok
pourquoi est ce que les campagnes de
communication d'appel au vote elles ne
se font pas là où sont les jeunes
pourquoi elles ne se font pas dans les
formats qui intéresse les jeunes et donc
il ya une responsabilité habilité
gouvernementales là dessus il ya aussi
une responsabilité ça sera mon dernier
point qui est une responsabilité
politique je parle je fais un peu de pub
personnel mais quand on fait une affiche
qui s'appelle mâcon président des jeunes
mais sous un code netflix ont fait un
choix qui est un choix qui peut être
clivant mais de dire que pour parler aux
jeunes il faut utiliser les codes qui
sont ceux de la jeunesse et donc quand
on reprend les codes de netflix on
attire l'attention en positif ou en
négatif peu importe on attire
l'attention sur le débat public et
ensuite notre responsabilité c'est de
dire la politique ce n'est pas que du
spectacle que de la communication c'est
aussi du fond mais il faut un moment
réussir à accrocher des gens qui ne sont
pas dans le débat public il rentre pas
dans le débat public et nous le
parti-pris qu'on aura pendant cette
campagne c'est de continuer un peu
parfois à transgresser à faire des
choses qui des fois peuvent un peu
choqué faire débattre parce qu'on est
persuadé que faire revenir les jeunes ça
passe par la capacité à les attirer vers
débat public voilà à la fois sur
l'intérêt du débat public donc sur la
faune sur le fond sur la forme et en
même temps sur les outils de
communication c'est les pistes qu'on a
envie de développer pour les quelques
mois qui nous restent avant l'élection
présidentielle
tu parlais du sii j'ai en plus d'autant
plus intéressant que on considère qu'un
jeune sur deux est aujourd'hui mal
inscrits sur les listes électorales et
donc c'est un coût supplémentaire au
vote alors que le vote normalement doit
être on le fait en sociologie électorale
en sociologie de l'abstention plus le
vote est simple et plus on voit tu n'es
tu peux être très curieux de de
t'entendre auguste sur à la fois le sens
qu'on redonne au vote et aussi sur cette
question de l'inscription sur les listes
électorales puisque vous avez travaillé
dessus au mouvement démocrate et avec
les jeunes démocrates oui tout à fait
déjà je tiens à vous remercier tous
d'être présent d'avoir répondu à cette
invitation à débattre et je remercie
d'orient pour la petite histoire
ce débat il part de l'idée que
il faut une réaction à ce taux
d'abstention dramatique qu'on a vécu
notamment aux dernières régionales
départementales
et ont tous les mouvements de jeunesse
présents ici en quasiment tous je
n'espère pas me tromper on avait signé
une tribune ton tu étais tu étais à
l'initiative dont j'ai accompagné
l'initiative donc tu as accompagner
l'initiative de grégoire cascarra du
mouvement les engager voilà tout à fait
et ce qui prouve bien que la question
elle nous préoccupe tous et quel
qu'elles cassent un peu les clivages
habituels on peut se retrouver sur des
positions qu'on peut se ne pas se
retrouver aussi sur certaines questions
relatives à ça et je vous emmène je
remercie devenir venir échanger là
dessus ici au vent démocrates nous ça
nous préoccupe particulièrement ça a
commencé déjà à nous préoccuper
sérieusement après les municipales on
on a on a mobilisé de la matière grise
sur la question et on continue de le
faire
pour répondre à ton interrogations sur
le sens du vote moi je vois dans
l'échéance qui finit devant nous en 2022
quelque chose de paradoxal c'est à dire
que l'élection présidentielle c'est
l'élection qui passionne c'est
l'élection phare de la vème république
je suis assez peu inquiets sur le taux
de participation aux prochaines
présidentielles je pense que je ne pense
pas qu'on va avoir un effondrement comme
comme on l'a vécue par contre el assa de
pervers l'élection présidentielle quelle
qu'elle se résume en tout cas la
perception qu en ont beaucoup tenant
compte de nos concitoyens elle se résume
à être un casting finalement
ont d'ailleurs on voit le nombre
d'émissions de télé qui pipeau lise
la chose moi moi personnellement je
trouve ça je ne pense pas que c'est par
ce genre de moyens qu'on va qu'on va
résoudre la question de la participation
électorale
et
le mandat présidentiel est un mandat est
perçu comme un mandat représentatif très
strictes c'est à dire où le finalement
le citoyen n'intervient plus il élit un
président tous les cinq ans et après
advienne que pourra il applique sa
politique et doudou les crises répétées
qu'on peut observer et qui sont pas
propres comme cana convient d'y vivre
si on revient un peu en arrière les
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy et de
françois hollande on observe des crises
à intervalles à intervalles réguliers
et à mon sens et je pense que c'est
partagé par mon mouvement vu les
échanges qu'on a en interne
cela est dû
au fait que l'acte de voter et
finalement réduit à déléguer à choisir
quelqu'un qui va traiter les affaires
publiques mais non plus à s'investir et
à traiter soi-même les affaires
publiques le citoyen il ne fait plus
qu'un casting il choisit il choisit qui
va décider pour lui mais il ne
s'investit plus dans la décision
politique et je ce phénomène qui
découlent de l'élection présidentielle
enfin c'est le diagnostic que je me
permets de poser il a imprégné tout
toutes nos institutions un bios vers le
bas et j'en prends pour preuve la
réaction qu'un certain nombre de
candidats aux municipales ont eu les
dernières municipales en 2020 je pense
qu'on peut tous être d'accord pour dire
qu'on n'a jamais autant entendu parler
de démocratie participative
le conseil participatif de budget
participatif de conseils de quartier
d'instruments tour pour essayer
d'inviter le citoyen à s'investir de la
décision publique en cours de mandat
et je pense qu on a beaucoup à apprendre
et on a de quoi s'inspirer de ces
exemples comme moi je suis un chien
passé ceux qui me connaissent le savent
je suis un passionné de de la
décentralisation de du travail des élus
locaux j'ai souvent c'est là que les
choses sont expérimentés et qu'elle
méritait d'être diffusé à plus haute
échelle et je pense qu'on a beaucoup
apprendre de ces des initiatives de nos
mères de nos conseils municipaux sur le
sujet notamment dans l'animation de la
campagne présidentielle la construction
des programmes
aussi des campagnes législatives
et je pense que c'est le rôle d'un
mouvement de jeunesse un peu je préviens
je préviens man mouvement de bousculer
un peu les habitudes et de dire non il
faut y
est de dire non il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on revoie un peu ce qu'on avait
l'habitude de faire et là en
l'occurrence je pense qu'il faut qu'on
acte la campagne qui les campagnes qui
nous attendent en 2022
sur ce format là
je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on s'en
inspire après pour gouverner
la crise des gilets jaunes il y avait il
y avait eu une demande forte qui
revenait qui revenait qui revenait
c'était l'idée du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
nous avec les jeunes démocrates on
rappelle une chose simple c'est qu'il
existe en instrument dans la
constitution qui s'appelle le référendum
d'initiative partagée mais qui en l'état
est
particulièrement compliquée à mobiliser
donc nous on demande très simplement
qu'on assouplissent déjà
après l'initiative citoyenne pourquoi
pas mais quand on commence déjà par
heure par ce book ans ce serait déjà une
une première avancée considérable
pour redonner aussi du sens à l'acte de
voter
ce commencent à être connues mais au
mouvement démocrate on est convaincu
qu'une règle électorale efficace est qui
et qui attire qui donne envie de se
déplacer dans l'isoloir cédric règles
électorales juste et on demande la
proportionnelle reste la proportionnelle
toute la proportionnelle
une une règle électorale non seulement
juste mais aussi une règle électorale
lisible ce qui nous a fait ce qui nous a
portés particulièrement préjudice je
pense notamment pendant la séquence
départementales régionales c'est que
pour
avoir fait quelques marchés notamment
avec sarah un canton quand on aborde un
électeur qu'on lui présente le tract
qu'on lui explique qu'il faut aller
voter dans deux semaines dans trois
semaines
quel casse-tête pour expliquer la
régionale lui alors c'est un scrutin de
liste mais il ya des listes dans chaque
département mais y'a une tête de liste
au dessus des têtes de liste des
départements et la répartition des
sièges elle ce feu enfin même d'où je
pense que si on fait si on fait une
interro écrite pourtant on est tous on
est tous engagés on on a tous militer
pour les régionales je suis sûr qu'on
n'est pas tous d'accord on a un on n'a
pas tous compris comment se répartissent
à laisser aux régionales c'est pas
normal c'est juste pas un oracle et ça
fait partie des choses qui font le rejet
de la chose publique et qui font que les
lecteurs va dire ben moi j'aime bien
faire dimanche c'est tellement compliqué
leur affaire et forcément il ya quelque
chose de louche de banet
le débat technique tutu m'interrogeais
pour qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans la
perspective de 2022 je pense qu'on peut
pas tout on peut pas tout chambouler là
on arrive on est un peu juste en terme
de timing mais il ya deux choses je me
suis permis de le glisser à notre notre
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
jeunesse et d'engagement le glisse aussi
à isabelle qui qui est dans une mission
mission parlementaire sur le sujet qui
ont entamé des travaux
qui touchent en particulier les jeunes
tu parlais de ma l'inscription
électorale on a quelque chose qui ont
qui à mon sens ce n'est pas normal
c'est c'est qu'on n'intègre pas la
réalité à la reid réalité étudiante dans
dans la les modalités d'inscription sur
les listes électorales je m'explique
quand on
quand on atteint 18 ans ont besoin de
quatre cartes d'électeurs et on est
inscrits automatiquement sur les listes
électorales de sa commune de la commune
on a un vécu jusqu'à sauf que patatras
quelques mois après
on est amené à étudier ou à faire son
apprentissage tout vent souvent on bouge
on quitte la commune de ses parents et
pourtant on vient d'être inscrit dans la
commune de ses parents et on est face à
tout un tas difficultés administratives
la réalité du logement étudiant en
france fait que c'est pas toujours
évident de justifier de son attache dans
la commune dans laquelle on étudie
entre les colocations les laisse les
seuls les sous location est souvent
c'est les plus précaires en fait qu'ils
ont du mal à justifier de leur de leurs
attaches communal et donc à la précarité
sociale vient s'ajouter une précarité
citoyenne qui est qui est juste pas
normal avec les jeunes démocrates on
demande une chose c'est que dans le code
électoral soit en justifie d'une attache
dans la commune pour pouvoir être
inscrit il ya les petites exceptions qui
a été fait pour les commerçants quand on
est commerçant dans une dans une
quelques uns qui s'invite dans le débat
quand on sait la biodiversité exactement
50 ans
quand on étudie dans une commune ça m'a
perturbé du coup
et ça continue ça continue et de pardon
lui les commerçants merci isabelle
les quand on est commerçant on peut
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
sans vie dans la ville en question nous
en demande une chose simple quand on
étudie quant on justifie d'une
inscription pédagogique ou d'une
inscription administrative dans un
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
dont une huile on devrait pouvoir
s'inscrire
ça me semble de nature vraiment à
résoudre les choses
et deuxième chose dans la perspective de
2022 faudra qu'on en reparle au sahara
mais je pense qu'on a une grosse
campagne
d'appel
à l'inscription à faire sur les campus
on a on à améliorer beaucoup de choses
ces dernières années et notamment
maintenant on peut s'inscrire jusqu'à
six semaines avant une élection et il
faudra le rabâcher le redire leur dire
moi je me souviens 2017 des camarades de
fac qui qui se retrouvaient dans les bio
devant les bureaux de vote le jour du
second tour et qu'ils n'ont en fait
c'est à 300 km cg papa maman ça ça va
pas être possible et ça c'est très
simple c'est très simple à régler pour
2022 je pense qu'on a des choses à faire
merci aux gosses
d'autant plus sensibles à cette question
que et donc c'est un bandeau de
publicité personnelle je viens de créer
avec d'autres une association qui
s'appelle à voter qui soit justement se
mobiliser sur ces enjeux de
d'inscription sur les listes électorales
et je serai très heureux d'en discuter
avec vous plus tard
la page de pub est terminée antonin
s'est vu prendre plein de notes
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que le sujet tu
évoques pour qu'on on évite la
génération abstentions
et bonjour à tout le monde et merci
d'avoir été ce débat qui est très
chouette ben en fait j'ai un désaccord
sur la vision qu'on a de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui parce que la démocratie
c'est le vote et c'est pas que le vote
j'ai trouvé en faisant des petites
recherches pour préparer ce débat un
sondage qui montre que 94 % des jeunes
croient en la démocratie c'est plus
qu'avant la chute du mur de berlin
c'est plus que la moyenne nationale donc
les jeunes sont particulièrement
démocrates ce qui fait qu'ils sont
particulièrement exigeants
donc pour eux le vote est pas quelque
chose de naturel d'évident ça c'était
une génération avant qu'ils votent
systématiquement en mettant ses beaux
habits comme on va à l'église ou un
enterrement au mariage c'est pas une
institution la jeunesse elle s'engage le
plein de façons en termes quand vous
arrivez en terminale et que vous êtes
lycéen vous avez plus d'une chance sur
deux d'avoir une activité politique que
ça soit signé une pétition fait d'eux
les oeuvres de charité de solidarité
d'être engagé un syndicat ce qui montre
qu'il ya une très forte participation
politique des jeunes une forte attente
est une exigence je rejoins ce que tu as
dit ambroise la participation aux
européennes elle montre une chose est
jeune il se déplace quand ils ont envie
quand on parle des sujets qui les
intéressent quand vous avez un débat
comme on a depuis la rentrée qui est
pollué par les thèmes qui ne concerne
pas dans nos conditions de vie quand on
parle du prénom des enfants ou quand on
parle l'accueil des réfugiés n'en dirai
pas plus et ben en fait on pollue le
débat et quand on entend des ministres
dire qu'ils vont jouer au dur avec des
polémistes d'extrême droite et ben les
jeunes se sentent un peu en dehors de
ces débats ce qui nous concerne c'est
l'écologie c'est la justice sociale ses
conditions de vie ses les luttes lgbt
pour le droit à l'égalité et c est quand
les partis politiques quand les
candidats les portes les jeunes n'ont
pas de problème à s'engager il ya suivre
derrière ces leçons des européennes
une forte participation qui était autant
sur l'enjeu de l'europe que de
l'écologie puisque on n'oubliera pas que
s'inscrivait dans le mouvement démarche
climat la politique elle marche comme ça
il ya des mouvements social de fond qui
a une lime la société et qui vont
ensuite comme des vagues
séchoir se concrétisait se transformer
dans la sphère électorale c'est comme ça
que n'est une idée est née dans un
milieu intellectuel et des reprises par
des syndicats par des associations qui
la font monter et ensuite on trouve des
gens et qu'ils ont mis une cravate et
une chemise on leur dit allez vas te
faire élire et défend la au parlement
dans les institutions
bah oui c'est comme ça que ça marche et
aujourd'hui il faut constater que les
partis politiques n'arrivent pas à faire
cette transformation il ya des
mouvements dans la société il ya nous
avec nos manières de parler un peu
anciennes ça a été évoqué par d'autres
intervenants avec des mots parfois est
un langage politique qui est un peu
compliqué à comprendre et entre les deux
une barrière qui est un peu hermétique
il ya plein de raisons à ça et je pas là
pour faire une thèse sur logis mais pour
dresser quelques perspectives je pense
qu'on pourrait travailler sur la façon
de s'engager je vous donne un exemple
j'ai une petite soeur qui est lycéenne
et ça fait un peu mon thermomètre de la
jeunesse et je la vois souvent partagés
sur instagram des publications de
raphaël glucksmann qui s'est engagé sur
la question des ouigours qui était pas
quand il a commencé à la question la
plus entre digoin des mois le terme un
peu sexy ce n'est pas un sujet dont on
aurait pu imaginer une mobilisation
massive de la jeunesse et pourtant la
façon dont il l'a fait a permis aux
jeunes de participer à des histories
donc un message de femer sur une
application qui s'appelle instagram pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
fait le poids au quai boomer c'est un
nouveau pas du tout mais on parlait des
moyens numériques et ensuite ça
permettait de s'impliquer parce qu'on
partage et la pétition il y avait des
appels à au boycott de marques
impliquées dans en chine et donc ce
n'était pas simplement raphaël ousmane
qui arrivait en disant jeunes fait comme
ça il leur donnait l'opportunité de
participer de s'impliquer c'est tout un
héritage que je pense on doit il va
reconstruire dû faire deux jeunes
acteurs y compris au sein du parti
politique est aujourd'hui c'est pas
complètement le cas une des pistes pour
moi ça pourrait être de renouer avec la
tradition de l'éducation populaire qui a
fait énormément pour politiser notre
jeunesse en fait la troisième république
dire ces mots ici un sens particulier
historiquement quand elle s'installe en
france sur le long terme elle s'installe
parce qu'il ya des hussards noirs de la
république parce qu'il ya des mouvements
associatifs des réseaux d'éducation
populaire qui vont aller sur les
millions de personnes faire de la
pédagogie transmettent de la
connaissance et transmettre le goût
politique le capital culturel de social
qui donne la légitime légitimé de
s'engager je les ai un bouquin ce matin
et j'ai été ravi d'apprendre un truc ça
plaît l'élagage g parce que vous savez
ce que c'est c'était un grand truc
d'éducation populaire au 19ème et qu'on
fait les résistants sous l'occupation
c'est une lecture collective douvres âge
et donc on prend des ouvriers parce que
souvent à l'époque il était et littré et
on va prendre un ouvrage alors j'étais
un peu les textes marxiste parce que
c'était l'époque et la mode mais on
pourrait prendre des ouvrages plus
actuelle par exemple des livres
d'économies et ses lions le travaillant
avec des gens plus instruits et en
collectif c'est un acte politique les
gens allaient découvrir cet ouvrage
débattre dessus et ça allait être un
vecteur de politisation qui est ensuite
allé leur permettre d'avoir la
légitimité d'aller sur l'arène publique
parce que il faut bien reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes qui s'engagent
et beaucoup des jeunes qui ont des bac +
5 et qui sont d'une certaine catégorie
d'étudiants assez favoriser je suis
d'accord avec ça je vois que tu enfiles
dernier point
je pense que on doit aussi laisser la
place aux jeunes quand ils veulent
s'engager parce que il faut des figures
l'appropriation il faut les
représentations qui donne envie
à gauche on à alexandria aux crises aux
cortès aux états unis qu'un symbole
absolu et qui pousse des générations
entières de jeunes à s'engager et
aujourd'hui on les a pas complètement
donc le message est on en parlait avant
et je pense que tous mes camarades sont
d'accord pour le dire le mode message
aux partis politiques on va dire
traditionnel c'est aussi un peu place
aux jeunes place aux jeunes quand il
s'agit de prendre la parole s'il arrive
souvent de se faire couper ou d'être
considéré moins légitime parce qu'on est
jeune et place aux jeunes aussi sur les
places électorale parce que les bras
tout à l'heure des jeunes républicains
disait on est souvent là pour coller des
affiches puis on a un peu oublié quand
il s'agit ensuite de mettre en place des
politiques publiques qui nous concerne
voilà je peux pas être plus long et
merci beaucoup
antonin
au plus tôt oui j'aimerais juste réagir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit en propos
d'éducation populaire moi je pense que
vous ne voudrez pas j'en ai un peu
entendu sur le gouvernement je veux
faire un petit peu de défense je pense
qu'on a on a fait on a tenté une
expérimentation qui qui me semble très
intéressante pour renforcer justement la
participation électorale chez les jeunes
c'est le s est dû
pour en avoir fait quelques uns je sais
que ça ça soulève des questions ça
soulève des débats mais pour eux pour
aller il faut toujours aller voir
concrètement pour en avoir vu
concrètement quelques uns sous les yeux
il ya des députés européens qui défilent
des députés nationaux des maires des
préfets
c'est l'explication grandeur nature de
ce que c'est l'action publique la
politique dans ce pays et qui fait quoi
qui sert à quoi et je
dernière petite chose je pense ce qui
est dramatique dans le taux d'abstention
des jeunes sur les départementales
régionales
quand on quand on est quand on a 18
entre 18 et 24 ans on vient de sortir il
n'y a pas si longtemps de trois ans
glissé de 4 entre collèges lycées gérés
par les régions que l'algérie par les
conseils départementaux bien souvent à
aucun moment on l'y voit c est qu
on rate une occasion terrible de faire
de la pédagogie sur ce qu'est la
démocratie territoriale en france à quoi
ça sert et voilà je voulais simplement
dire ça
je vous propose qu'on prenne une
question de la salle d'erwan balanant
député du finistère qui je fais a
beaucoup travaillé sur les enjeux de
participation citoyenne notamment nos
remedial chez eux merci merci moi je
suis super content de voir ce moment
parce que voilà c'est bien pour notre
mouvement politique de se dire qu'on est
capable de réunir toutes les forces de
jeunesse politique du spectre je vais
dire républicains et les modérés et je
suis assez fier qu'on puisse faire ça
[Musique]
je voulais
je voulais aussi les féliciter parce que
faire le choix de venir c'est pas
nécessairement évident il aurait pu
tomber sur une salle hostile mon cas on
reste en reste deux
je vais faire très vite parce que je
voulais apporter un petit élément de
réflexion alors je suis comme avec
isabelle on est tous les deux dans la
mission que que richard ferrand a mis en
place sur l'abstention on a commencé à
faire un certain nombre d'auditions et
on a commencé aussi à regarder un
certain nombre de chiffres et c'est
important
l'abstention des jeunes elle est
historiquement et tout le temps plus
forte que l'abstention des moins jeunes
donc il ya un effet de seuil sur la
question de cette élection les dernières
où c'est dramatique partout donc la
question de reculer faire reculer
l'abstention ce n'est pas qu'une
question de jeunesse et je pense qu'il
faut le dire parce que quelque part à
chaque fois on stigmatise les jeunes
mais les jeunes ils ont historiquement
moins voté et il ya des problèmes
comment dire des réalités et tu l'as
bien dit auguste sur la question du
jeune qui vote acquis qui votent à
quimperlé quand il est étudiant à paris
enfin dire c'est compliqué donc c'est un
c'est un vrai sujet par contre ils
jouent alors premiers éléments je vous
avais été un certain nombre à vous dire
les politiques ne parlent pas aux jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité constante
quand moi j'avais votre âge
j'avoue que raymond barre ne me
parlaient pas tant que ça donc voyez
bien donc non mais donc c'est pas non
plus le seul sujet dans le vrai sujet en
réalité c'est qu'il faut notre monde
notre société énormément évolué il ya
des éléments de de rénovations à faire
est de 2 comment dire de voix la maison
république et la maison démocratie a
besoin d'être un peu restructurer et
cette restructuration elle passe tout
simplement et c'est un élément que je
mets au débat sur l'articulation qui a
entre la démocratie participative la
démocratie représentative qui est
extrêmement importante et crée cette
démocratie continue faire en sorte
qu'entre les élections dans l'instable
interstices électorale on ait envie de
continuer à s'engager et prendre en
compte effectivement et se dire que la
démocratie ce n'est pas que le vote je
crois que c'est c'est la démocratie
c'est aussi l'engagement citoyen et tout
ça et ya un travail à faire des pouvoirs
publics et et sarah le fait de redonner
le goût de l'engagement à la jeunesse
mais pas qu'à la jeunesse à tout le
monde et ça passe évidemment par la
jeunesse et à partir du moment où on
s'engage dans la société où on est
d'accord de participer de donner un peu
de son temps à la société naturellement
on a envie de voter un moment donné et
je crois que c'est ça qu'on a perdus
dans notre société peut être par un
certain individualisme
ce goût de l'engagement pour l'autre
goût de ce que moi j'appelle l'empathie
politique c'est à dire la préoccupation
pour l'autre et là vous êtes un bel
exemple que rien n'est perdu et que on
va y arriver parce que notre démocratie
on va la sauver évidemment
en clonant peut être un mot sur
démocratie continue
bah va falloir changer de république
pour ça
va falloir changer de république pour ça
parce qu'en fait
l'individualisme c'est un peu le truc
facile de comptoir de café sans vouloir
être péjoratif envers vous
et ouais de dire bah oui c'est plus
individualiste et en même temps les gens
ont besoin de commun on voit qu'il ya un
besoin de solidarité donc je suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse simplement dire les
gens sont égoïstes et font leur vie dans
leur coin je pense qu'on est dans des
institutions c'est de la scène
république qui enferme et jean pourquoi
si toi qui disais tout à l'heure il va y
avoir une grosse participation à la
présidentielle parce que les gens savent
que pouvoir y est à l'elysée pourquoi
est ce que les gens participent pas aux
départements aux régionales cas - bah
ils sont pas bêtes ils seront donc il ya
moins de pouvoir donc c'est bien de le
dire ici il ya des auteurs qui depuis
longtemps ont dénoncé le caractère
centralisée hyper centralisé
personnalisée de la saga publique pierre
mendés france dans la république moderne
faisait déjà à l'époque il va falloir
faire un effort si on veut intéresser
les gens à la politique michel rocard
écrivait déjà il faut des colonisés la
province et que touchera pas décidé par
100 énarque à paris donc oui il va
falloir un changement institutionnel un
peu courageux
heroes ce point on peut se rejoindre
mais ça va demander un peu de courage
politique
alexandra cloud est une réaction
sur la démographie continue qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque ou qu'est
ce que cette
grande question
je pense que ça ce matin là dessus
après
alors simmons qu'en fait je voulais un
temps je voulais y réagir sur plusieurs
points
depuis le début d'un jeu
je salue sarah parce que je suis à
nantes donc en fait
on est au même endroit ça très bien
et en fait il ya plusieurs points
non parce que j'étais candidate ou
départementales brook
est justement donc pour réagir sur le
point des candidates au départemental en
fait je reviens moi je peux pas
totalement la question mais je reviens
sont un pas qu'on a abordé tout à
l'heure qui est que les parties doivent
laisser plus de place aux jeunes et là
dessus je suis entièrement d'accord et
c'est que nous c'est vraiment en tout
cas chez les républicains c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment dans le parti
dans l'adn du parti depuis que christian
jacob a été élu à la tête du parti c'est
vraiment de laisser la place aux jeunes
ce qu'on en parle tout à l'heure les
jeunes ne sont pas là que pour coller
des affiches et pour tracter c'est fini
cette politique c'était un minet
les jeunes aujourd'hui ils sont là pour
réfléchir ils sont là parce qu'ils ont
envie de parler et en fait c'est comment
est-ce que là ça rejoint un peu ta
question de démocratie continue entre
guillemets mais en fait continue au
c'est très bien mais continue dans le
ton et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas aller
chercher un jeune pour une élection et
lui dire c'est très bien alors là pour
les présidentielles j'ai besoin de toi
parce qu'il faut à l'école il faut aller
tracter il faut lire sur les marchés et
puis une fois que l'élection est passée
à ben en fait tu as quelque chose à dire
on s'en fiche non la démocratie continue
c'est aussi donner la place aux jeunes
sur le long terme c'est les inviter à
des cercles de réflexion les invite à
réfléchir leur fédé faire participer au
programme nous chez les républicains
voilà on a fait notre entrée début
septembre on avait présenté plein de
propositions qui ont été repris par lé
par le parti pour faire le programme
présidentiel on n'a pas encore de
candidat mais au moins d'un problème
c'est déjà ça un progrès bientôt et bah
oui ça vient de tomber on fait un
congrès bon voilà comme ça je vous le
dis maintenant mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui est super important vraiment
donner une place aux jeunes et donner la
place aux jeunes leur permettre aussi
d'être sur des listes c'est pas juste
aussi lors les fait réfléchir s'ils de
leur laisser le chemin là comptera
possible d'émettre son avis moi j'ai eu
la chance d'être sur les listes
municipales j'ai eu la chance d'être
candidate aux départementales alors ok
je suis une fille et à droite on n'a pas
beaucoup donc du coup on a besoin de
filles mais c'est aussi parce que on est
là pour qu'on est là parce qu'on a des
idées et parce qu'on doit s'investir et
ça c'est très important
antoine nolwenn d'un mot qu'est-ce qui
est mocratie continue
en deux phrases et karembeu n'ont même
pas si tu veux moi je me méfie toujours
des néologismes je sais pas ce que c'est
la démocratie continue
oui mais je suis né je suis né je suis
en tout cas quelque chose que chérie
c'est la démocratie représentative
et là dessus je crois que ça on doit la
garder on doit la défendre et
malheureusement je suis désolé de dire
ça aussi c'est à dire que c'est vrai que
nous on est là entre jeunes on ne sait
pas si on est très jeune dans la salle
mais j'en vois beaucoup en tout cas on
n'est pas représentatif forcément des
jeunes de la société et je suis désolé
de dire je sais pas si le clivage gauche
droite existe encore ou europe anti
europe mais il ya un clivage qui est
vrai et qui représentait
sociologiquement actuellement dans le
pays si les perdants de la
mondialisation contre les gagnants de la
mondialisation et là dessus dans ce sens
là on va dire que je connais pas la vie
de chacun j'ai pas là pour juger mais
quelque part nous on fait partie d'une
d'une frange qui est plutôt tu le disais
tout à l'heure plutôt diplômés bac + 5
on s'exprime bien on est à l'aise on est
bien entre nous mais un moment pour être
représentatifs c'est pour ça que je
tiens ce terme là il faut aussi que nous
faisions de sign forces pour aller voir
les jeunes et les motiver là dessus pour
aller voter et se présenter et enfin je
termine et je sors du sujet mais il ya
quelque chose dont on n'a pas parlé
actuellement j'ai juste évoqué au début
c'est à dire que j'ai pas où est la
caméra mais en tout cas si les jeunes
doivent nous entendons c'est que ils
doivent aller voter tout simplement ils
doivent aussi parce que c'est pas juste
aux élus de laisser la place aux jeunes
c'est aux jeunes de les prendre aussi
ces places là et toi alexandre tu l'as
alexandra tu l'a certainement prises
aussi ta place mais c'est bien celui
d'hier c'est positif ce que je dis donc
à un moment ne nous réfugions pas
uniquement vers derrière la super
structure mais prenons aussi notre place
et aux jeunes d'aller voter et de
s'investir eux-mêmes dans la vie
municipale et dans la vie politique pour
prendre eux mêmes leurs responsabilités
je pense que sur quelque chose sur
lequel on va tous d'accord c'est
favoriser l'engagement des jeunes et les
développer un développer la formation
militante
aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes ne se
sentent pas légitime à être sur des
listes et a participé vraiment à la vie
politique
mais on a pu voir lors des intersections
mais aussi chez europe ecologie les
verts depuis un bout de temps que les
jeux sont présents sur liste et c'est
pas seulement un nom sur une histoire de
dire regarder en ennemis des jeunes
maintenant vous pouvez vous sentir un
petit peu concernée est représentée non
sont des jeunes qui ont été mis par
exemple sur les listes régionales très
très haut moi même j'étais candidate aux
élections municipales et les élections
départementales et tout de suite on se
sent avoir une légitimité et pouvoir
vraiment donner nos voix notre notre
parole et nos idées et dans le même sens
dans la verse les jeunes ne vont se
sentir représentés knox est ce important
que ça fonctionne dans les deux sens et
qu'on laisse vraiment la place aux
jeunes pour construire un programme pour
être présents sur les listes et pas
juste être un ongle le jeune de la liste
voilà
en bref le jeune avec macron comment est
ce qu'on fait cette légitimité de tela
lajnef qui veut s'engager comment est-ce
qu'on lui
sur le fond est peut-être sur comment
est-ce que de manière plus générale on
est capable d'attirer les jeunes à la
politique au delà de l'échéance de 2022
moi j'avais deux sujets sains qui n'a
pas été abordée encore métier la
question de l'éducation comment est ce
qu'on est capable à un moment dans notre
système éducatif et je le dis en
présence de sarah mais aussi je sais pas
si nathalie et est présente mais il y a
ici des gens qui ont cette capacité là
c'est comment est ce qu'à un moment
notre système éducatif est capable de
faire passer des messages et on est nous
tous plutôt jeune on peut constater la
défaillance majeure de l'éducation
civique et morale au collège et au lycée
c'est pas ça qui donne envie d'aller
voter et donc potentiellement là dessus
il ya un travail à faire à la fois sur
comment est-ce que le message passe
peut-être qu'on avait fait une
proposition au gouvernement de d'avoir
un moment une parole qui soit porté par
les jeunes sur ce qu'est la république
et sur le sens du vote c'est à dire que
peut-être que les jeunes qui parlent aux
jeunes ça a plus de sens que des gens
qui sont entre hymne est déconnecté de
la génération il ya ce travail là à
faire de repenser l'éducation civique
repenser le rôle des institutions
l'explication y compris sur le rôle des
institutions territoriales
je sais que ça te tient à coeur au but
c'est donc sur ce travail-là d'éducation
civique on a des avancées à faire je
rejoins ce qu'il a dit est juste aussi
le s est nul pour le coup on est
d'accord là dessus mais il y à des
modules là dedans et je pense qu'on peut
en mettre plus d'ailleurs des modules
d'appel au vote de compréhension de ce
qu'est notre démocratie qui sont
absolument essentiels parce que comme
tous les jeunes passent par ce creuset
républicain
à la fin on obtient des résultats
puisqu'on est sur d'avoir touché tout le
monde en plus dans un cadre où hier un
mélange de population avec des gens qui
ne sont parle pas forcément d'habitude
est donc là on peut confronter des gens
qui sont effectivement des gens
intéressés par la chose publique et les
gens qui ne le sont pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les mêmes origines familiales
pas les mêmes origines sociales et donc
ce travail là je pense qu'on peut le
faire aussi au travail du service
national universel ça c'est sur la
partie éducation et puis ensuite sur la
partie considération de montrer aux
jeunes que l'engagement de manière
générale la démocratie mais aussi le
vote certes à quelque chose la première
chose c'est que je rejoins le constat
sur le fait que les jeunes s'engagent
plus sur des causes et que ce n'est pas
forcément parce que ils viennent pas
voter qu'ils ne sont pas intéressés par
la chose publique on est totalement
d'accord là dessus petite anecdote ma
petite soeur qui a 16 ans partage aussi
des story de raphaël glucksmann et je me
dis mais tu sais que tu sais que tu sais
qu'ils engageront politique pour le
parti et lissa faye annonce n'avait pas
du tout mais voilà c'est raphaël
glucksmann c'est les ouigours et elle me
parle des who de la même manière donc
c'est bien la preuve que même des gens
non politisée peut avoir cette à trélat
et puis donc sur la façon dont on a de
con à de donner le sens du sens à
l'engagement il ya la capacité à écouter
ce que disent les jeunes et là je parle
plus à notre majorité
je veux dire que quand on fait des
propositions quand des mouvements de
jeunesse des propositions et que ses
propositions sont reprises et qu'elles
sont appliquées qu'elles changent
concrètement la vie des jeunes eh bien
on montre aussi l'intérêt de
l'engagement politique j'ai une fierté
dans ce quinquennat c'est qu'on a fait
des propositions au moment de la crise
sanitaire c'était peut-être pas
suffisant peut-être pas assez peut-être
pas si peut-être pas ça mais simplement
pour vous donner cet exemple précis qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur on
avait proposé en janvier l'extension des
repas un euro crous des boursiers vers
tous les étudiants ça a été repris par
le président de la république deux
semaines après notre proposition et je
peux vous dire qu'en tant que président
de mouvements de jeunesse quand j'ai eu
les remontées de terrain des étudiants
qui sont engagés chez nous qui nous ont
dit on a un problème là dessus sur la
capacité qu'ont les étudiants à manger
qu'on fait cette proposition et qu'on
voit qu'elle s'applique concrètement et
qu'on à servir 11 millions de repas
crous à 1 euro eh bien il ya une fierté
de l'engagement parce qu'on se dit qu'on
a changé concrètement le quotidien de 11
millions de doses millions de repas et
ça c'est
je pense que au delà des angles au delà
des différences politiques on peut pas
faire mieux que d'avoir une réalité
concrète de ce qu'est l'action et puis
enfin je termine là dessus parce que je
pense que ça vous tient à coeur sur les
modalités du vote à la fois sur la
modernisation de ce vote le vote par
correspondance le vote peut être
électronique en tout cas je pense qu'il
faut qu'on adapte notre démocratie à la
société dans laquelle on vit et sur la
représentativité sur les jeunes ça a été
dit je reviens pas dessus je pense que
tous les partis sont en train de prendre
conscience progressivement en tout cas
ce que j'entends parce que moi j'ai la
sensation qu'on le fait chez nous je
crois qu'il ya quelques maires j'ai pas
ce qu'ils ont dans la salle mais je sais
qu'il ya le maire de port marly le maire
de villepreux il y en a quelques-uns
chez les jeunes démocrates que je veux
saluer parce qu'ils travaillent en plus
dans les yvelines en bonne intelligence
avec notamment aussi maire de tarnos
c'est un maire jeannot on a fait ce
travail là dans la majorité je
honnêtement plutôt satisfait j'ai
l'impression que c'est le cas chez les
autres aussi en tout cas aux régionales
on a affronté beaucoup de jeunes au
départemental aussi donc voilà c'est
plutôt bon signe et puis à la question
la représentativité et je vous le dis
ici avec non sans amusement et avec un
clin d'oeil très appuyé vous pouvez
compter de manière très appuyé sur le
soutien des jeunes avec macro pour
défendre l'importance de la question
proportionnelle dans les scrutins
c'était facile mais c'était sincère
merci beaucoup on arrive au terme de cet
échange et les baux de la fin j'aimerais
les empreintes et alexis de tocqueville
qui disait que dans les démocraties
chaque génération est un peuple nouveau
j'aimerais vous remercier très
sincèrement chacun d'entrés vous d'être
venu ce soit
la voile le disais tout à l'heure
c'est pas un exercice facile et a
remercié également le mouvement
démocrate et les jeunes démocrates
puisque on manque encore cruellement je
trouve dès ce passe comme ça pour
croiser les regards les les visions les
projets les les récits on ne manquent
cruellement et surtout à sept mois d'une
échéance comme celle qu'on va qu'on va
connaître merci
[Applaudissements]